all right well let's just jump into this
first story we got this from Fox News
Atlanta cop City Anarchy Sees at least
35 agitators detained part of an
International Group suspects from France
Canada and out of Georgia among those
arrested in significant escalation at
Atlanta's police and fire training
facility we got a video here from Andy
Noe on YouTube which I will play just a
portion of so you can see just some of
the scale of this degree of extremism
this is a government facility there's
there's what looks like power lines
construction equipment and hordes of
people running in and ransacking things
now of course you've got many on the
left trying to claim that it's not
organized it's just a demonstration it
was all impromptu blah blah blah but
that is absolutely not true you have
people who have been occupying this
location for years you have an
individual who was killed by cops after
shooting a cop
people who have burned down houses one
private citizen had his truck set on
fire and flipped over these are
extremists who have been occupying this
area for some time they brought in guns
from across state lines believe it or
not I know I know
shocking isn't it and they organized
this they are ransacking another
government facility they are funded this
is look at these videos I mean some of
this is crazy huge groups of people and
they're calling it
they're calling it a demonstration I
think Fox News even calls it this they
say
a group of agitators
left the nearby South River Music
Festival around 5 30 pm and descended on
the construction site of the pros
Atlantic Atlanta Public Safety Training
Center to conduct a coordinated attack
on the construction equipment and police
officers
all right here's the issue here's why I
won't call a demonstration here's why
I'll say it's organized here's why I
won't say these people were arrested you
see what Fox News says 35 detained I
guess detained is better than arrested
an arrest is when like a hippie marches
in the middle of the street waving a
little flag or sign and they say sir you
are obstructing a roadway and he says we
gotta end the war and they're like if
you don't leave the road you're getting
arrested he says I refuse they arrest
him bring them to the station he gets a
slap on the wrist they let him go that's
an arrest
when you have outside forces from
foreign countries and people coming from
across the across the United States
under a shared Banner flying a flag of
an active organization with websites to
recruit people receiving funding who has
previously been engaged in Insurgency
and Terror attacks like that guy in
Washington who said he was antifa and
firebombed the nice facility I am sick
of them Fox News everybody constantly
downplaying it and being like no no no
everything's fine because I will say
this before we get into the bigger
conversation
you know I have to talk about Civil War
and I have to wonder
maybe there won't be a civil war
because that would require more than one
faction and if the left right now is
able to engage in this degree of
terrorism and its terrorism and even Fox
News is like they're just being detained
because they're agitators then there is
no opposition then all they are is well
we have now talked down the violent
extremism of an ideological Fringe
faction to the point where it's a
protest that's acceptance
so what happens well the police won't
arrest these people you've got drag
shows for children adult performers
dancing for kids the cops won't arrest
those people anyway at all it seems like
whether you want to accept it or not
they've won already and so what may be
coming is not going to be a civil war
but a culture revolution in which case
we will see more of this we've got a
bunch of stories in this regard we could
talk about as well California is
imposing a new rule that if movies are
not woke they will lose tax benefits it
is being enshrined in law so anyway now
that I've ranted a little bit I don't
know if you all agree with me but uh
what do you think am I am I off am I
have I lost it no I think the upside of
this situation if you could really call
it an upside is that the people were
arrested 35 of people were arrested 23
have been charged thus far as four hours
ago or something like that so there has
been some response yes captured and on
their way to being indicted perhaps what
I think about the framing is renditioned
yes let them be renditioned
I'm kidding about the auditioning
because you have a gathering and then if
a gathering starts gets gets directed
they might turn into a protest it's
still a form of gathering a protest then
if the protest gets violent it becomes a
riot it's still a form of protest and
it's still a gathering and then but it's
the Colorado so you have to defer to the
most violent aspect of the Gathering and
call it that you are correct and then if
it's been two years of an organized
group in this one area and they've shot
a police officer put him in the hospital
and they have guns and explosives and
Molotov cocktails then they recruit more
people under a shared Banner from across
the country and other countries to
descend on a government facility to Fire
Bomb equipment and attack police
officers and forces of Law and and
agents of the government I think you are
well past riot
yeah this was an attack they attacked
the compound right it's a terror attack
and they were arrested justly sorry Phil
what did you say let's call it an
offensive there you go it was uh it was
aged offensive yeah it was a stage
defensive it's a faction of violent
extremists who are organized
International with allies weapons
explosives using lethal Force to destroy
a government facility we're we're in the
we're in the beginning phases of a
cultural revolution in the United States
similar to the one that happened in
China I think we're at the end of the
beginning phase the beginning phase was
weird wokeness and movies having you
know a plethora of interracial you know
gay sex scenes oh yeah 911 getting us
all to hate each other
I would like to finish what I was saying
because I don't wanna I don't want that
getting cut off what I'm saying is
California enforcing by law now that you
have to have these ethnic quotas and
gender quotas I don't care if a movie is
gonna have you know interracial gay
dating or whatever people can make
whatever movies they want I'm talking
about the enshrining and law of it yeah
I was interested in getting some funding
one time and I was looking up Government
funding and stuff like that for the Arts
and I noticed that there was these
requirements that was your either part
of the LGBT community a person of color
all the whole list you know whatever
that whole list is and you can get some
funding but nowhere in there was
anything that I qualified for like being
a white CIS straight woman Siz what does
that mean that sounds like a slur
it actually is considered a slur Yeah by
a lot of people but I just found it
interesting too yeah they do yeah
because I've been attacked on you know
social media where they're just like you
CIS your CIS and it's like very like
antagonizing it's it's insulting but I'm
just making that point where like I was
looking for funding and how can I get
out there and make some arts and do do
something and get some government
funding and I I found that there was
nowhere for me to get funding
yeah I completely think that we're in
the middle of a cultural revolution I
think that and unless we have uh
concerted effort by your average person
to push back on these uh these type of
well first of all these activities you
have to have people that are going to
say look we want law enforcement to do
something about this
um and so far I don't think the
population in the U.S has really decided
that they're they're fed up with it and
until the population starts pressuring
their representatives uh you're not
going to see any kind of significant
change and I'm too scared exactly I
don't think that that they're I don't
think I tell you this man
you know a civil war requires multiple
factions deciding that their ideology is
correct but when you have a passive
faction and an active faction I don't
think you get Civil War you get
Revolution the far left right now has
just laid Siege to a government facility
with people from outside this country
and the media is is protecting it even
Fox News Fox News should outright say
terror attack no question when when the
when the Overton window has shifted to
the point where you can get a band of
people over several years shooting at
cops fire bombing government facilities
and it's called agitators at a
demonstration then you've already
normalized what they're doing to the
point where you accept it this legis
This lends credibility to what uh Rusty
Rockets was saying on Bill Marshall that
uh MSNBC Fox News they're all the same
ah he's wrong you think he's wrong he's
absolutely wrong
wrestler
Russell Brand's great but I did correct
him earlier on my uh Tim News YouTube
channel yeah if you look at the News
Guard rating of MSNBC it says proceed
with caution not credible and Fox News
is deemed generally credible I don't
hate that Fox and Fox News like then
okay look foxnews.com factual news
reporting with a conservative tint MSNBC
opinion conspiracy video garbage yeah
Fox News on cable TV mostly
straightforward news all day until you
get to Tucker Hannity and Laura Ingram
and then Tucker is actually pretty good
but a little snooty and snarky people
like him for it MSNBC all day is
conspiracy garbled nonsense so Russell
Brand goes on Bill Maher and says you've
MSNBC is the same thing as Fox News it's
biased nonsense blah blah blah it's like
well he mentions why won't they talk
about Julian Assange in Snowden then
it's like Tucker Carlson does so Fox
News is not in that camp you've got the
populists and you've got the cultists
and MSNBC is the cult conspiracy channel
has been wrong basically about
everything yeah I think that there he
was kind of extending an olive branch by
saying hey both sides have issues guys
but the truth is the liberal economic
order is utilizing that media
organization whether it's MSNBC or CNN I
don't know how they are owned they're
owned by similar structures or whatever
I mean he's always been an
anti-establishment so I see why he's
saying that he's always been kind of
against all that but I feel like he's
starting to kind of see the light a
little bit more on the right more than
he used to in the past when I when I
went on Russell's show the first time
they invited me I was kind of like it's
gonna be an ambush they think they're
gonna like get me with something but
that was a good conversation Russell's
he's a smart dude I think he's and he's
genuine absolutely yeah and I I he he
had me on his show again recently I
think he's fantastic I just think there
there are many people who are who are
late to the party and I don't mean that
disrespectful exactly I'm glad they made
it to the party at all hope they brought
some pizza or wings or something but
don't come empty-handed Russell is
bringing a horde of followers and people
who believe in him and trust him he's
been a populist on the left for for a
long time calling up calling out the
machine he's now seeing exactly how
broken things are he's calling it out as
it needs to be but
I don't think he watches Fox News I
think he's still of that world where Fox
is bad but now he realizes MSNBC is bad
and so he's like hey wait a minute
that's exactly if you're on the left and
you hear Fox News Fox News Fox News is
what they do then you watch MSNBC you go
hey wait a minute that's exactly what
Fox News is doing ah it's exactly what
they told you Fox News is doing and what
they used to do they warmongered hard in
2008-7-6 uh for the Iraq afghanistans I
mean that was the the right the the war
Monger uh they called him neocons at the
time and it was like this this yeah the
Republican Party by the The Cheney
Dynasty and George Bush Jr you know
they're a huge War I mean and seeing uh
Fox parrot at that really really they
were really disingenuous in those years
and thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
on censored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time